well this is the latest health check
from the international monetary fund on
the state of the UK economy and let's
just show you what they were forecasting
last time around this is showing you not
just the UK you can see that over there
on the right hand side the Red Bar there
but also other economies around the G7
The Group of Seven industrialized
economies and you've got the us there
Canada Japan and you can see look
Britain does have the weakest growth in
2023 and when I say great that's gross
domestic product growth the rates at
which our national income is growing
each year so that was the last time
around that was only a few months ago
have a look at these latest forecasts
look at the Red Bar there look it goes
up it goes up from minus 4.3 percent to
0.4 still pretty weak by the standards
of recent years but nonetheless not the
weakest in the G7 anymore a lot of
people are asking if the IMF can make
big mistakes like this in their
forecasts how much should we trust their
numbers anymore this is what I put to
the managing director how important is
it how big of a deal is it if the IMF
does keep getting things wrong does that
damage your rep reputation do you think
I actually think that
our staff my colleagues deserve credit
for being agile in how we look at
changing conditions and being fast
to adjust projections so we can give as
clear a picture as we can at the time
that you would agree is the focus we
have seen in many decades one other
thing the fund is talking about is the
idea that inflation so the rate at which
prices are rising each year could be
stickier than people that expected
what's that mean well this line is
showing you inflation the rate at which
we are seeing that cost of living
increasing you can see how it's gone up
into double digit levels uh recently
here's what the bank of England recently
thought that was going to happen to
inflation it was going to come down
quickly they thought in November they
thought it would come down really
quickly when they did updated those
forecasts in February they thought it
would come down even more quickly so
look at that blue line now the latest
forecast and the IMF basically endorses
this look that blue line goes even
further out into the future so higher
inflation for longer and they say that
also means that interest rates
potentially could be higher for longer
all of these things that are squeezing
people's living standards could go on
for longer than anyone would like